There's a lot of talk lately about what
role the privatization of space might
play in our future ambitions of space
exploration and from where I sit,
there's a lot of delusional thinking
there.
For example,
unlike what Newt Gingrich said in a
presidential debate there he is saying,
had we given the money we had given to
NASA,
to the private sector,
we would have been on the moon and Mars
by now and we'd have done it more
cheaply and everything would be fine and
dandy.
No,
it doesn't work that way.
Private enterprise in the history of
civilization has never led
large,
expensive,
dangerous projects with unknown risks.
That has never happened because when you
combine all these factors,
you cannot create a capital market
valuation of that activity.
The first Europeans to the new world,
we're not sailors on the Dutch east
India trading company ships.
It was Columbus,
it was Magellan,
and these were voyages funded by
governments.
Somebody has to draw the maps.
Somebody has to see where the dangerous
spots are,
where it's safe,
what the prevailing winds are.
Once that is established,
then private enterprise can come in and
say,
here's the risk.
I need an investor.
Here's your payback.
If we can turn this into an enterprise,
so no private enterprise is not going to
lead us to the moon.
They're not going to lead us to Mars.
What'd be nice for them to do is take on
our low earth orbit.
Activity's been there,
done that back in the sixties.
Low Earth orbit was a frontier we didn't
know who can humans survive?
Can you even swallow?
If you were in orbit,
would saliva get caught in your throat?
Simple questions like that were unknown
and unanswered at the time.
We're well past that.
We know how to get to low earth orbit.
It's done.
The patents are offered or given
granted,
and so that'd be the ideal place for
private enterprise to take over.
Tourism would easily drive that much
money.
Americans in the world spends on
tourism.
You can have a tourist lotteries if
where you could win a much more
expensive vacation than you could
otherwise afford.
I certainly buy lottery tickets if it
meant taking a vacation in space or
rather in orbit around Earth,
which I guess we'll still call that
space.
But if NASA is advancing a spaceman tier
that's Kinda really just driving around
the block at that point,
but that would,
could surely sell tickets and I'd.
I'd be first in line.